[Music]
so yeah
um
the restrict Act
Tick Tock band yeah what do you think of
that I mean I did you see the hearings
it's the hearings see some of it yes did
you it was crazy did you by chance do
you watch meat Canyon at all oh I don't
think I saw no no okay do you ever watch
his cartoons no okay I need to can we
play should we play something I mean I
feel like I should show you the one that
you just did about The Tick Tock it's
disturbing though okay you know the meme
you know the meme where this like this
woman and she's like uh Mr whatever oh
yeah take a look at the screen okay did
you see that actual did you see that I
did I didn't see the video they actually
played well crazy about it was the video
they actually played
wait I think it was the real video
it had like 400 likes or something like
that's how out of touch which is I'm
saying is a low amount of yeah they're
so out of touch that they're like this
video is threatening democracy it's like
nobody saw that video they're so at
least pick one that people actually saw
yeah something viral like uh yeah Mr Chu
can you direct your attention to the
screen please
hey got a bag of Great Value tots here
gonna see if we can't put this in my
deep fryer if you know what I'm talking
about
get that out there
[Laughter]
oh [__] it I think I can fit a couple
more in there
I told you it was [__] disturbing
better not leave these in too long I
think I got a couple of them starting to
pickle
so Mr chill that video didn't go viral
that was my video what does it take
exactly for someone to get at least 20
30 000 likes on your platform
I don't I don't really understand the
question if I can interject if I can
interject
20 000 lakhs seems more than reasonable
wouldn't you agree Mr Chu at least 20. I
don't miss you miss you
if you could direct your attention back
to the screen please
get the game on the bottom you can't go
that's great wow so funny yeah it was so
wild it was so wild to watch it's almost
like the first adult it's it's the first
big trial in my lifetime where I feel
very invested like in the subject matter
and feel like wait this is crazy this is
like uh and the people you know
obviously what you're noticing in the
trials that these the people that are
sort of coming out against it
they're not it's so clear that they
don't even know the thing that they're
talking about that's just that's just
Congress though like that's always like
that when it comes to Big technology
it's like they don't know anything it's
so weird I do think that there is
like some some sort of validity to this
not the restrict act because I didn't I
didn't realize like how actually
intrusive that whole
thing was like it's not just about Tick
Tock it's about like being able to
gain access to like any of your your
devices if you so sketchy like you can't
use a VPN to like I know I know and you
could be fined a bunch of money yeah
which seems pretty [__] intense and
that does not seem like uh
I don't know yeah it's terrifying but
like Tick Tock itself
being Chinese owned yeah yeah and that
sort of stuff I think that has some sort
of yeah I mean I agree that it's like
it's like well it's not coming from
nowhere they're not just like they're
not just like what can we make up
they're also like they're like well this
could be a this could be a concern I I
have no expertise on how much it really
is but yeah I I agree that there's
there's something to it probably yeah I
mean it's it's interesting to hear your
perspective because you like I love Tick
Tock yeah I know I just it's just this
thing that I love that I'm just like
it feels I think as someone who
basically loves Tick Tock I love how
organic it is its rise has been so
organic like it's the way it's blown up
has been so organic that
it feels not so what it feels like to me
is they're like hey you can't just do
that you can't just like win the game uh
you know and and then they're just
trying to but it also felt to me it felt
like it felt like these people that
aren't on Tick Tock going we're tired of
hearing about Tick Tock like shut it
down you know yeah like I'm not on Tick
Tock I and then it really is exemplified
when she sort of is like look at this
video and the video has like no likes
you're like oh yeah you don't like even
understanding what's viral how something
goes virals I don't know or like house
something like that affects people's
lives and their careers yeah yeah yeah
but I'm hoping I mean yeah I hope they
can just kind of figure it out and then
and then keep it going it seems like
there are lots of different ways where
they could they could make it work where
IT addresses any security concerns and
then I don't think there's that many I
mean I think one thing would be they'd
go public in the states right right but
they have to like make sure that
it's just it's weird right now because
the code is all owned by a Chinese
company so like they very well could
even if even if they spun it off and it
became an American company they could
potentially like there could be back
doors in the boat and stuff like that so
I know
it's true it's true it's definitely
interesting because it is I mean I can't
imagine like that would have such a
cultural impact right now if it just
went away I know because it's everyone's
definitely everyone's most used social
media app I feel like is that fair to
say right now yeah I think so and what's
besides YouTube people would I think go
over to Instagram more and Instagram
reels and the the pitch you know what
people are saying is that that's what
this whole thing was about was it was
like Zuckerberg sort of behind the
scenes pushing Tick Tock to get banned
and then it sort of worked and then but
people are like well we're not gonna go
over to Reels of tick tock expand I'm
like I think we are I feel like we're
gonna be like well where's the other app
where I can just scroll I don't you know
I wouldn't I you wouldn't yeah I would
wait till something came along that was
similar more similar to tick tock
Instagram still just feels like it's
like clunky clone yeah and it's too many
different apps yeah it's just so much I
don't even I still don't really
understand Tick Tock is so simple it's
so clear yeah it's just like get here
and zone out just like just start
scrolling and it's all like it's just
videos you know do you think that there
is something
to be said about like the damage like
Doom scrolling and the effect it has on
your like mental state because that was
always the thing that everyone talks
about with Tick Tock it's like you you
go like more so than any other social
media app like people speak about it
like as if it's like a video game where
it's like yeah I got on four hours went
by right where it felt like I blinked
and all of a sudden now I feel [__]
depressed yeah you know when I I
remember my first engagement with Tick
Tock and I thought this is so dystopian
I feel like I'm in a Black Mirror
episode because you're just doing this
and you're like suddenly in someone
else's house and someone you're in some
you're in someone else's house it's like
I have that feeling you're like I can't
stop yeah yeah stop yeah yeah yeah yeah
I guess I do I guess I do see that yeah
it makes you sort of engage with the
real world less and
yeah I don't know yeah maybe it's all
maybe we'll go hiking more if it gets
banned yeah maybe that's what we're all
yeah we'll all turn to the mountains